it's the YouTube cool hey kevin van org
Emma's kevin van or die Justin hey Walt
hi guys uh welcome to the show we're
gonna talk about some news starting with
some that just broke like an hour to ago
yeah so there was an activision
financial call this is today financial
reporting and exciting things like that
and so we were listening to them and
they just kind of dropped evolved going
to come out in February 2015 now to KR
activision uh 2k everybody i'm sorry
it's everybody's financial call today
act i just came from the activision one
got everybody's calling their finance
guys and like look man I can't I don't
know if I'm gonna make this happen this
year I gotta push evolve it's more it's
a big call that you sit in on and they
just talk about number it's really
boring but you can't but you have to do
it because you can get news out of it
yeah and every now and then they drop
something like this where evolve is
going to be pushed to 2015 the fact that
it comes during a financial call
probably says that this is more of a
financial reason than anything else it
is not a developmental reason that they
didn't run into some huge problem and
we've seen the game multiple times that
it seems really close to being done yeah
it was really it's in really good shape
so far it was not a game that you play
and get the impression like this could
use a few more months yeah you don't
play that game and think this needs more
polish that game looks really good if
somebody's really well unfinished game I
played probably so a couple more months
to to make things a little bit better
guess it's gonna hurt it i'm sad i was
there any news were so crowded like yeah
this is better this is good news all
around october is a crazy cluster f I
was though February's the new October
did they say februari 2015 februari 2015
okay so they gave a proper date for it
and we did they say anything about the
beta because they were gonna do some
exclusive Xbox one type beta situation
so this is more this was definitely more
other investor call like giving them
information so not for us I'm sure we're
gonna hear some more information about a
beta coming up soon and how we how us
plebeians will be able to get in and
play it but I don't have the urban
mortals kevin van word or a mere mortal
i hate to break it as well at least i
know he's a god path of exile's game
you've been playing a lot over the over
the past year yeah and there's
new path of Exile coming down the pipe
yeah there's an expansion coming out on
the 20th so called forsaken masters and
the whole deal is they're like these
seven masters that all uh that all
opposed ominous who's the big who's the
big bad of path of exile okay they were
forsaken you know forsaken yes and and I
go look we're seeing some of the
metaphor shaken one yeah so master so
the the big thing for us was uh we we uh
we dropped a little exclusive on the
third master that was announced whose
name is El rhian and he's kind of a
martyr type guy who likes punishment
yeah i was reading your like article
don't like this uh masochism stuff he's
like oh my church is forsaking me now i
just want to like die doing something
heroic he wants to die he's actually
kind of pissed that every time like the
player comes in and adeline saves saves
him and and and he he's protecting the
relics is like this whole thing where
he's a little little pissy already alive
these aren't people that you play as
these are like they have missions
associated with them new areas that you
explore um well not not really a new
area but you'll come across the seven
different ones as you go through so the
first time you play like on regular
difficulty you'll probably come across
each one of them either once or twice
but as you keep going you'll you'll get
to do more and more stuff and then you
unlock a hideout which is kind of like
like kind of your guild hall if you want
or your your player housing and your
house yeah do you get successful mines
it are you guys all sims ii is there a
phase that like these sort of massive
games reach like the player house
threshold like once you've once you've
got a player house in there where you
can like buy a sofa to put in there
you've got jumped the shark like they've
gone player house no i don't know like
that that were there was a time when
that was the kind of thing you just
expected from the beginning okay i mean
anarchy online you got like a house from
the very beginning and you know
everquest two you got a house from the
beginning and like your wife's car yeah
Kirby's Epic Yarn you have a house you
have a house is Sean I know you're the
Mara be multiple you two down at the end
of the couch our big animal crossing
fans so is this I mean there's a new
house you guys can customize are you in
on path of Exile been playing path
Ephixa but I am similar
more intrigued now that I get a house
can I like paint things and put in bring
animal friends and I haven't done that
whole like I haven't seen it in person
yet but my understanding is that there's
like a light of Sims like you know like
customization and I pay off my life debt
to tom nook like is that a part of the
sequence or what I'm gonna say yes okay
I'm gonna say yes that we're just gonna
go with yes I let's go with yes well I'm
glad they put that in there having a
house of course the ultimate fantasy
unrealizable fantasy for anyone who
lives in the bay area so nice and I get
to live that out in a video game Kevin
when can people play it when is forsaken
masters hitting path of Exile 20th 28
login to the highest when you thanks
Sean August good I you down echoing down
the Winslow I'll something august all
right Sean uh sorry Kevin a gap you're
just gonna stay down there for a little
bit Sean actually you were gonna pop in
on this one too because it says I'm not
going anywhere it's Assassin's Creed
rook rao real shrewd rogue rogue Bruce
rogel it's assassin creed Rouge and it's
about how Maybelline is now the new
Abstergo Abstergo has got a cosmetics
department jolly and it's among its
mind-altering uh cuz ya so the only
thing was a good game that was funny in
my brain there's a new game let's go
what they came at one who knew this was
coming yes I think with codenamed comet
coming up to this is coming it was the
specifically the ps3 and xbox 360
Assassin's Creed game that they hadn't
yet discussed and of course the big you
want to focus on xbox one ps4 PC because
the unity version is the one that is
gonna look really hot we got to see the
basically a mood trailer which is not
the way the game is going to look right
it's a CG trailer it shows off the new
hero whose name is Steve rogue okay no
it's actually we just like philly
brother Harry or more match shape extra
korma he is a Templar he's an assassin
hunter so like assassin's creed 4 was
the first game in the series where
you're actually not playing as an
assassin for the bulk of the game like
eventually Edward does become an
assassin but he's just doing his own
thing for like seventy-five percent of
that game he's basically Sarah Palin
he's going rogue yeah it's got yeah
there you go there's a
there's a photoshop contest and shooting
wildlife or in this case assassins in
this case people people like yeah this
guy who's asking for a hand so here's my
question he's actually stranded on this
ice floe and like the northern Atlantic
yeah like does he need to shoot him
can't he just leave him to die Sean if
you if you leave if you don't smite him
down he'll come back stronger than you
could ever imagine I mean that's a video
game that that Killins 1101 yeah he's
gonna become a nice monster he also you
didn't kill answer he could still be
alive that sort of had a moment of I'm
going to shoot you know I'm I want to be
your friend or like I'll just leave you
to die and then Lord no I shot that
polar bear that was sniffing this is
more satisfying to pull a trigger of a
gun than to just stand there and let the
elements take their toll just watch The
Life seep out of him that's right but
then neither primarily others and it's
perfect because then is a zombie yes and
thus the game of thrones assassin's
creed crossover yes complete done done
and done do we know when we're gonna
hear more about this game or when it's
going to come out or anything like that
well it's in the future August twentieth
no it's it's no different yeah this is
another little early this is the one
that has a coincide with unity the one
that you know all the people who don't
have current gen consoles are gonna be
able to play and we just haven't heard
as much about it because you know they
want to pimp out unity and that does
look really cool and it's gonna I'm sure
it's gonna be a lot of fun but this is
the one most people are gonna buy
because it's the one all the color you
think so you think about selling the
install basis like leaps and Metis
multiple times bigger 360 ps3 the done
there's pc we should have a prize we
know unity is the only one coming to pc
yeah fortunately NPD only tracks retail
sales so that's true digital sales who
cares i really wish they had chosen a
name that wasn't like a really common
developer platform for that assassins
creed assassins creed unreal that I've
been better yeah essence Creed havoc all
right last knows story we're gonna talk
obsessions Creed Photoshop sorry last
one on a second screen my uncle one more
actually it's not the last mile would be
great Assassin's Creed Microsoft off
that would be cool
just make that Mel Gibson my movie into
an assassin's creed thing so Assassin's
Creed word Apocalypto assassins created
word speaking of Resident Evil a new
Resident Evil game was announced and
it's not really known as such it's mold
but you again people all things only
knew through the magic of video games
what is real deal here what's it called
resident evil hahaha I'm actually this
is there some cutesy name for it juanita
re remake resident evil HD I would
assume hasn't there been like eight of
those already so listen I'm actually
pretty excited about that this is the
gamecube re-release that that only came
out on gamecube there was that point
many years ago when capcom made an
agreement with Nintendo what we're only
gonna bring some games out to gamecube
no other consoles we had beautiful Joe
and resident evil and then Capcom was
like nobody's buying these resident of
four was one of those games it's what
and resonating you are game key keyless
and then it came out to everything else
this was one of the games that never
came out to any of the other consoles
like playing resident evil you've
basically had to play the playstation 1
version and that's it and this this
version looked really great I mean oh
you can see how the screens it was a
great update I mean we should say it is
not a note for note remake of the
original resident evil they did some
significantly different things and I
remember being much harder on the
Gamecube was a little bit harder yeah
but I sure you didn't just grow weak in
your old age true yeah Gamecube yeah I
have grown weak to challenges and any
sort of like significance well we saw
you playing rogue legacy earlier yeah
it's a baby game and if you had problems
with the controls or anything like that
I think it's interesting that they're
gonna include the tank controls but if
you don't want to thank centrioles you
can control it like a real game they're
also but not one of those fake gamer
games not a kannada tanking you're not a
tank when you're not to take you're a
man or them and they're also adding in a
camera that I guess will pan around so
you'll keep that cinematic view all you
got in the game but it'll kind of show
make it look more realistic in the way
that it transitions between stages but
you can also turn that off of you just
want the regular resident evil the slide
read slide spot yeah the fixed kit well
that fixed camera was like for me it was
like key and making that really
terrifying
well then I think the demon no matter
what is going to be in there yeah but
it's just the way that it transitions
between seems like when you go in the
door it's just not gonna suddenly be
like up in the middle of nowhere to like
slide over so you can see how it yet
sort of like is it's a gentle pan it's
not you know you're not moving it around
or anything like that all right are you
guys gonna play it when you don't know
one hundred percent yeah I I have the
Resident Evil game key one has been
sitting next to my console and like I've
been like I don't want 13 years no I
played it back in the day and what I
want to play this again but I don't want
to bring out my wii and plug that in
this is an excuse not to have to do that
and it's going to be on pc so i don't
have to worry about not being like i can
still let this sit for another 13 years
and won't have to plug in something else
i can just download it on steam when
it's gonna go i'm gonna wait for it to
go on sale okay and it's just gonna sit
there and you all right here from now I
will play a perfect rice played it so I
Snowden playing three make get it it's
the third I could hear the are in the
ears Annapolis sorry II make three I was
even a clear we need healthy it
definitely helps when your voice is like
lilting up and down like that oh yes
sells the that kind of inflection is
really wait with three make we're gonna
I got it we're gonna have Kevin workshop
that a little bit but now we're gonna
roll